just work it out
well everyone's in a good mood and then
what do you think they're saying
we're both qualified we draw yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely we have to
make it look like a fight what about we
play this line with the queen sacrifice
and then the perpetual in the grunfeld
they will never
be on to us
that's ridiculous we've done that a
million times in the championship no no
no it's been a long time ago
we can bring it back
no just berlin all right
just apparently i will never know
and
oh my
i would laugh myself silly if they
actually
oh oh greenfeld no broonfield is it
going to be the line with the queen
sacrifice oh no
exciting
ship g7 knight f3 c5 rook b1
wesley do you remember the move
oh no different oh different ah okay
we got it all wrong knight d2 oh even
shorter knight c4 queen c3
should be two
queens maybe two bishop c1 come on guys
give us a queen sacrifice oh
there you go come on okay the people who
didn't switch to the iguana video
they're
really just